[Aplausos]
bem pessoal eu gostaria de começar
convidando vocês a embarcarem comigo em
uma viagem cósmica mas eu acho que a
maioria de vocês se não todos não
viajaria com alguém que não conhece
então acho que primeiramente eu devo me
apresentar melhor para vocês e contar
pra vocês uma breve história de quase
tudo da minha vida
bem eu sou nascido e criado na europa
eles município da baixada fluminense
e boa parte da minha infância com grande
parte da minha vida eu estudei aqui
nesse colégio foi aqui onde eu aprendi
as minhas primeiras palavras onde eu fiz
os meus primeiros estudos iniciais da
minha vida lá claro como acho que se não
todos a maioria de vocês já passaram por
essa pergunta o que você vai ser quando
crescer bem diferente da maioria dos
meus amigos eu não tinha dúvida do que
eu queria ser pra eles
era estranho a certeza do que eu queria
se ter como profissão no meu futuro e
pra mim era estranho ver como eles
tinham dúvida do que eles queriam ser
após se formarem
eu queria ser cientista engraçado
exatamente porque quando eu estava no
colegial a cada etapa da minha vida
desde do ceará que eu já no ceará
contava pra minha professora que o que
você pretende ser quando crescer eu
quero ser matemático eu quero trabalhar
a consciência ela bruno matemática não
dá dinheiro ea cada etapa que eu passava
na minha vida os a desmotivação era
muito maior as palavras para desmotivar
é muito maior do que as palavras para
motivar
o cientista no brasil é loucura
cientista no brasil morre de fome você
aluno negro de nilópolis município da
baixada fluminense
obrigado você acha que conseguirá ser
cientista
eu consegui
hoje eu sou físico faço as minhas
pesquisas aqui na uerj trabalha com
astrobiologia astrobiologia é a área que
estuda a origem da vida
o desenvolvimento ea evolução da vida e
também busca entender qual seria a
possibilidade de encontrar vida em
outros planetas
além de trabalhar com a minha divulgação
com o trabalho de pesquisa em
astrobiologia eu passei a trabalhar com
divulgação e popularização da ciência
porque eu achava necessário as pessoas
verem a exatamente aquilo que eu
enxergava na ciência não apenas pra
contar fatos não apenas para disseminar
o conhecimento científico mas pra
demonstrar a importância de nós
refletirmos sobre cada fato que passa
pelas nossas vidas temos uma perspectiva
diferente com cada coisa que está ao
nosso redor
exatamente porque dentro de toda essa
etapa da minha vida eu passei a pensar
eu conseguir
mas quantos exatamente igual a mim
homens negros mulheres negras
quantos que sofrem discriminação ficaram
para trás
quantos com dificuldade ficaram para
trás devido a uma simples palavra a qual
lhes trouxeram uma desmotivação para
permanecer na sua trajetória a palavra é
uma coisa muito forte é algo que pode
mudar a sua perspectiva e pode
transformar a sua trajetória
então qual a importância de nós temos
uma perspectiva para as nossas vidas
bem eu posso dizer que a grande
importância para as nossas vidas é a
forma de nós pensarmos encararmos a
nossa vida de uma maneira diferente
bem eu não faço divulgação científica
para poder transformar todas as pessoas
em cientistas a minha idéia de trabalhar
com divulgação científica principalmente
o trabalho de alfabetização científica
está na questão de você despertar a
curiosidade nas pessoas e não apenas
isso você continuar mantendo uma
motivação sobre questões científicas e
porque isso é importante você não
precisa ser cientista para você
conversar e gostar de ciência e falar
sobre isso com seus amigos
no entanto acredito que é muito
importante você ser alfabetizado
científicamente para você entender e
discutir questões que sejam políticas e
sociais que envolvam a ciência e por que
essas pessoas que são alfabetizadas
científicamente são diferentes da
maioria das pessoas
primeiro pelo caráter de curiosidade que
elas possuem pela senso pelo senso
crítico e pela forma de enxergar o mundo
de uma maneira completamente diferente
do que a maioria possui mas não apenas
isso quando você é alfabetizado
científicamente você possui o poder
você possui um poder de compreender
compreender fatos que são importantes
para a sua vida
citando thomas jefferson
ele disse a seguinte frase não basta a
segurar o povo certos direitos na
constituição o povo precisa de educação
mais do que isso o povo precisa exercer
o seu ceticismo
e educação do contrário o povo não
controla o governo
o governo controla o povo pode não
parecer mas quando nós não temos esse
caráter de pensar criticamente de nos
desenvolvermos através da alfabetização
científica nós estamos meio por fora
desse processo
nós estamos meio que por fora desse
sistema democrático
alguns de nós sem nem ao menos saber
simplesmente devido à falta de um
pensamento crítico e de um caráter de
alfabetização científica ou seja a sua
perspectiva de como olhar o universo o
qual você se está inserido
isso tanto como a curiosidade como a
motivação foi muito importante para
desenvolver o meu trabalho de divulgação
científico e aí eu gostaria de colocar o
principal motivo de eu estar trabalhando
com a divulgação científica hoje eu
quando estava cursando a minha primeira
faculdade de licenciatura em física
a minha faculdade era recém criada para
o instituto tecnológico aqui no rio que
não se encontrava com grandes condições
não tinha grandes nomes
os professores eram professores recém
formados ou seja eram recém doutores e
eu pensei poxa eu vou na uerj vou na
ufrj eu vou em tantas universidades e eu
vejo aquela sede de conhecimento dos
alunos
aquela vontade de você querer aprender
mais e na minha faculdade a gente apenas
assistir à aula
vez ou outra quando o professor permitia
conversarmos com ele após terminal à
aula mas a gente não tinha informação do
que a gente
ia ser eu acredito que grande parte de
vocês no ensino médio
com certeza existe grande dificuldade em
saber o que é cada uma das carreiras
imagina o que é uma carreira científico
que é um ser um físico ser um químico um
biólogo um astrônomo isso não é
privilégio ou deste privilégio do ensino
médio durante a graduação eu como grande
parte dos meus amigos nós não sabíamos o
que era seu físico
e aí entra também a grande questão o que
nos faz universidade
a gente não sabe quando entra na
universidade
o que nós podemos ser além daquilo que
nos foi colocado inicialmente você vai
ser um físico você vai ser uma
administradora mas o que está além disso
por isso comecei a pensar vou formar a
minha 1ª semana acadêmica coisa que
nunca te vi semana acadêmica que eu vi
em várias universidades
o problema é que eu fui tentar ser
ousado
eu pensei vou tentar convidar um físico
que é muito famoso talvez você conheça o
professor marcelo gleiser e vamos chamar
para participar da nossa primeira semana
difícil mas quem são consciência acharia
aqui um garoto de nilópolis sim
condições financeira numa faculdade
recém-criada receberia resposta do
professor marcelo gleiser
ele não apenas respondeu e depois de
dois dias como ele falou que aceitaria e
participaria do evento eu muito
emocionado fui falar com o coordenador
professor olha só eu consegui a resposta
do professor marcelo lelis ele irá
palestrar
a gente pode fazer a nossa primeira
semana de física vai ser um grande
evento e acho que vai motivar os alunos
mas prosseguir com a sua carreira
ele falou pra mim bruno você como aluno
de graduação você não tem o direito de
fazer uma semana acadêmica difícil você
como a 1
graduação você não teria não tem o
direito de conversar com o professor
doutor
caso você queira eu como doutor posso
conversar e aí de doutor para doutor
pensarmos em acertar até porque você
como aluno de graduação
quem é que viria o seu evento bem a sua
amiga que está ao seu lado tem um
professor aqui ouvindo a nossa conversa
de repente ele participa e como eu sou o
coordenador do curso eu sou obrigado a
participar então a gente teria por volta
de mais seis pessoas bem o evento não
aconteceu lá na instituição
mas da mesma forma que eu não me deixei
me abater e que eu não me desmotivei com
outras palavras que passaram por toda a
minha vida eu também não me abati nessa
questão fui até uma outra faculdade
mostrei o projeto mostrei a ideia que
tinha sobre divulgação da ciência
conseguir o auditório para realizar o
evento e nós com apenas o dinheiro de
duas bolsas de iniciação científica
r$200 mil duzentos reais da minha colega
montamos um evento e esse evento deu 150
pessoas
o nosso trabalho permanece a gente
continua com esse trabalho de divulgação
e popularização da ciência através do
núcleo de pesquisas de ciências
hoje em dia os nossos eventos não têm
menos que 200 pessoas
fizemos um evento onde que aconteceu na
ufrj com 400 que poucas pessoas
isso para pensar que uma pessoa que era
graduanda e que não conseguiria colocar
mais do que seis pessoas em uma sala de
aula para uma palestra para um evento
bem e aí eu chamo a questão a
importância da perspectiva cósmica para
a nossa vida uma perspectiva não apenas
o que está próxima de nós
a perspectiva
é algo muito importante para a nossa
vida eu como físico talvez por causa
disso
veja a perspectiva como a característica
mais importante do ser humano
porque pra analisar qualquer sistema
físico depende de como estou observando
esse fenômeno e na astrobiologia não é
muito diferente
então pra mim
a perspectiva é algo que nos faz ter um
algo além é como se fosse uma
característica evolutiva para o ser
humano a cara com a perspectiva pode
mudar e transformar com o passar do
tempo eu tenho uma perspectiva do que
nós vivemos em uma frágil ilha na qual
está aí colocada em uma imensidão
cósmica de um universo de possibilidades
dentro desse universo de possibilidades
surgiu a vida a nossa história passou a
ser contado
as histórias são feitas de idéias e as
idéias informações todas essas nações
elas possuem as suas histórias contadas
pelas suas ideias e por seus conflitos
ideológicos
contudo eu acredito que para todos que
estão aqui ensinou a maioria a história
mais importante seja nossa própria
história é essa
como todas as outras histórias desde a
idade da pedra até os tempos modernos e
atuais toda escritura em rochas todo
livro cada texto
cada poema cada declaração de amor
cada mensagem com rede social cada
alegria risada tristeza e lágrima
derramada se encontra aqui
tudo e todos que conhecemos todos
aqueles que você ama todos aqueles que
você conhece se encontram aqui aqui e
aqui talvez quando nós passarmos a ter
uma perspectiva diferente de vida uma
perspectiva cósmica uma perspectiva que
vai além do que a gente consegue
enxergar hoje em dia a gente possa
entender um pouco o que nos faz
universidade que nos faz ser que nós
somos os nós não estamos
além do universo
nós fazemos parte de todo o sistema
político e social
nós fazemos parte de um ecossistema nós
fazemos parte da terra
nós fazemos parte do universo o universo
faz parte de nós
obrigado
[Aplausos]